[музика]
від самого народження і дотепер вони
постійно разом одна школа од мене
училище
ліцей завжди все разом
брати-близнюки Григорій та Олексій
кулачинський одні з наймолодших
рятувальників України Вони настільки
звикли і ти пліч-о-пліч що навіть
працюють в одній пожежній частині
щоправда завжди в різних караулах
тому що якщо ми були одне з Міні і хтось
знав зайшов позадивлене середовище
було б морально тяжкіше не знаю що що
він як там що він там починаєш
переживати і це буде сильніше душити
психологічний
хрещення пожежника брати-близнюки
пройшли минулого літа ще курсантами вони
рятували людей та розбирали завали після
ракетного удару Росії по Вінниці 14
липня тоді загинули 27 людей майже 200
постраждали тоді залучалися 100
курсантів Та десь офіцерів
спочатку було не по собі а потім
реабілітувалися
то знову почала Стрілок на загнали всіх
курсантів в
підвалтах
будинку Ми посиділи хвилин ми вже 12
може 20 потім нас випустили Ми пішли
дальше розбирати конструкцію і поставити
людей рятувати після завершення навчання
брати кулачинські влаштувалися в одну з
пожежних частин Одеси нині обидва
командири відділення посада
відповідальна Тим паче в Одесі в місті
яке регулярно зазнає ракетних атак з
боку Росії команди
[музика]
розвитку це
як найбільш досвідчення людина на пожежі
як як командиром свого відділення
і Хоча вони наймолодші рятувальники
регіону досвіду мають вже чимало адже
війна не лишила часу на поступово
адаптацію в роботі брати Одразу почали
працювати в надскладних умовах приміром
після кожного удару Росії по Одесі бодай
один із братів працює на місці руйнувань
так було і в ніч на 14 серпня коли
росіяни поцілили у супермаркет
дуже багато часу ми там працювали
Ми виїхали ще вночі під час тривоги ми
трохи з як сказати очікували Потім
почали вже повне розгортання почали
працювати гасити пожежу і так до самого
ранку ми працювали
десь годині 8-9 ми вже були частину
Там деякі ще працював проте найглибший
найболючіша війна вплинула на братів не
в професійному житті а в особистому на
початку літа відчим якого хлопця любили
як рідного батька загинув неподалік
бахмутають Україну в були в місті Бахмут
виконання своїх обов'язків батько під
час розмінування
міни він був командиром
з певної групи при розмінюванні був
обстріл
та Він загинув
при взриві це
найближча людина з нами жив знаю
спілкувався
частіше
рідко бачились бо вони були на
лінії на нульовій в бахмуті він нам дав
те що не давали не дав рідний батько
набу пору дав те що повинна давати
і нині на передовій
звикли до того що мати на війні адже у
війську вона ще з часів проведення АТО
Там і познайомилися зі своїм чоловіком
вони дуже багато вже пройшли
міст і останнє місце якраз
там де загинув батько вони разом
працювали разом служили так на гарячій
лінії там таких умовах вони
познайомилися потім їх
офіційно вже розписав зампотел
по військовому і так були одружені тяжко
і ми бачимо це розуміємо щоби без нього
і тяжко
що вона не може без нього нічого зробити
Раніше вона могла в неї було плечейна
яке вони могла покластися
яке знаходиться дуже близько Зараз в неї
нема
долі брати не втратили бажання
допомагати рятувати навпаки кажуть ще
більше почали цінувати свою роботу і
підтримку один одного ми працюємо для
того щоб допомагати
людям які не можуть зустрічати собі
допомогу
якби під час військового стану під час
цього всього що твориться
цієї війни якби
морально воно на нас не дуже впливає той
не робить з нас якісь
слабих або ще щось якби ми працюємо тому
що ми розуміємо що це наша робота все
наше обов'язки
і це треба нам це робити
роботу чи професію чи професію Тому так
і працює
попри війну будують плани нині брати
займаються вступом до університету аби в
майбутньому стати керівниками
рятувальних підрозділів так як хотів
Віталій відчим який замінив хлопцям
батька